du jour appelle les gouvernements la
parole est à madame véronique louwagie
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
hier vous avez annoncé un small business
act à la française se décline en 18
mesures pour construire et je vous cite
encore un gisement d'emplois autour des
tpe et pme dans une période où la courbe
du chômage ne cesse d'atteindre des
sommets vertigineux
pourtant alors que le projet de loi
macron visé à réformer notre économie et
le projet de loi raid s'amène celui du
marché du travail
vous allez introduire ces dispositions
par des amendements ceux qui ont dit
long très long sur la cohérence de votre
méthode
ces mesures mérite un débat de fond et
ce malgré le fait que vous avez appelé
un débat pragmatique devant l'assemblée
nationale et une pragmatique monsieur le
premier ministre de recourir à des
amendements et surtout à l'article 49 3
qui musèle le débat parlementaire comme
semble préconisé le président de
l'assemblée nationale au sujet de
l'encadrement des indemnités
prud'homales en cas de licenciement
certes certaine mesure nous semble aller
dans le bon sens comme celles par
exemple permettant de renouveler deux
fois assez d'aidé concernant la prime de
4000 euros pour les embauches nouvelle
notre pays compte 1,2 million
d'entreprises individuelles sans salarié
cette mesure qui vise à encourager toute
embauche d'une durée minimale de douze
mois devrait selon votre ministre de
l'économie créer de 60000 à 80 mille
emplois
outre les modalités de son financement
qui reste une nouvelle fois flou cela
semble un dispositif nous ont regardés
plus de 5 millions de chômeurs que
compte notre pays
votre politique n'est pas cohérente la
création du compte pénibilité le
démontre singulièrement car il s'agit
d'un dispositif d'une lourdeur extrême
pesant sur les entreprises de plus au
travers la réduction des crédits d'impôt
apprentissage vous avez mis à mal
l'apprentissage alors monsieur le
premier ministre
quand allez-vous prendre les mesures
structurelles et cohérente que nous
attendons depuis des mois car monsieur
le premier ministre
it's time to act il est temps d'agir
merci madame louve algie la parole et à
monsieur emmanuel macron ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
nouvelle si vous nous interroger d'abord
sur la méthode
mais quel autre méthode qu'un serré par
amendement dans des textes qui sont
précisément en discussion et dont celle
objets plutôt que d'en recréer d'autres
et pourquoi avoir attendu les annonces
d'hier parce que au mois de février et
vous êtes je pense comme nous le sommes
sensibles au dialogue social
le premier ministre a précisément
rassembler les partenaires sociaux leur
a demandé de travailler sur une série de
sujets en particulier pour faire un
bilan de la loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi a lancé une série de chantiers
qui ont trouvé leur conclusion ces
dernières semaines et en particulier en
particulier
la conférence se les pme tpe qui s'est
tenu précisément à l'elysée hier
les annonces d'hier seront traduites
dans la loi précisément ces prochaines
heures
pour ce qui est de la loi croissance
activité les prochains jours pour ce qui
est de la loi de modernisation du
dialogue social
les prochains mois pour ce qui relève de
des lois de finances et du vote de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
il ya donc quatre textes qui permettront
d'insérer ces mesures c'est une façon
aussi de rendre crédible des annonces
qui sont faites parce que ce
qu'attendent nos chefs d'entreprise
comme le salarié c'est précisément quand
l'eau transcrivent qu on le passe dans
la loi
c'est ce qui sera fait c'est ce
calendrier qui sera respecté
la longueur de ce calendrier c'est celle
du débat démocratique et vous ne pouvez
pas en quelque sorte nous faire des
reproches paradoxaux ou contradictoires
vous allez trop vite vous allez trop
vite en déposant des amendements du jour
au lendemain est en quelque sorte vous
ne nous laissez pas le temps en passant
par certaines procédures et il faut se
préoccuper de ce qu'est notre économie
qui réclame précisément des mesures nous
continuons à agir pour simplifier pour
accélérer pour précisément donner plus
de sécurité de visibilité à notre
économie
c'est l'objet des annonces qui ont été
faites hier par le premier ministre une
partie de ces mesures seront déposés par
amendement dans le cadre du débat en
commission spéciale à laquelle vous
participez sur la loi croissance
activité
il y aura un débat dans ce cadre puis
halimi ce mr
si monsieur le ministre la parole est à
m